what's going on there reject nation
we're back at it with superman and lois
season two almost done with it hey guys
if you can't leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also subscribe click
the notification bell to get notified
when our reaction to the final episode
is up thanks to the boys are prepper for
helping us edit down these reaction
highlights and yeah full-length watch
launcher sync over the top go for
superman lois
they're available for super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page let's see
what's going on i heard this episode is
a 12 out of 10.
[Music]
my parents died when i was young
i've had trouble holding on to work
don't even get me started about my love
life
[ __ ] you can be successful and in love
and
still feel like there's something
missing from your wife that's why i
wrote this book because that void can be
filled lucy lucy lane
nice alliteration
you're not lois lane's sister are you
that's me lois lame sister
what about your mother
she left when i was a kid must have been
painful
you understand i'm nobody lucy you are
somebody you're lois lane sister you
just had this conversation
why are you leaving
everyone please calm down
ally's been gone over a month she's not
coming back
[Music]
and lucy
[Laughter]
every season the title grows longer
there's no sign of valley anywhere you
think she went to the universe world
there's only one way to know for sure
you are not going back there you left me
with two teenage boys for a month yeah
that was hard compared to what clark was
doing yeah this is the hardest
suit looks like it held up well against
ally yeah
can't say the same about superman what
she can drain and absorb people's
superpowers now like some kind of energy
vampire not just powers oh colin
robinson anything i can do to help i
will take a breakfast burrito that
sounds so good can you open up the most
recent fall for the suit please of
course john
[Music]
snitch
was not
me seriously
let me see
are you at the bar where that woman is
when was this last night
dad set up the whole thing totally
surprised me and then just shoved me on
stage oh honey i
really wish i could have been there yeah
why not be at that bar not that far
[Laughter]
i can't believe your father took you
there
what was he thinking i don't think you
understand like he didn't no i don't and
we will talk no further about this we go
to school with sarah right i know i know
but lana isn't ready for sarah to know
the truth about our family so so
shouldn't that at least be up to sarah i
miss sarah
i don't want my girlfriend back oh do
you think she'll ever change her mind
i don't know but for right now we just
need to keep our distance
hey keep in my distance bright side i
planned a full day of chores for us so
we could spend some time together yeah
how is that the bright side oh come on i
used to love helping my dad around the
farm grandpa's dead what's the past
giant
hit on former first sergeant aaron wu
tracked her down to a lodge out in the
middle of nowhere is the d.o descending
in a team no it's just me and lois and
me
this is lane family business the lanes
aren't the only people involved in this
i am a part of this she's right see lois
is good
millions of ali alston's followers have
gathered to hear her address the world
as you can see
we
putting on a suit like this puts your
life in danger i know what i'm doing
you're gonna take this thing apart
oh my i build things
i don't destroy them one way to deal
with this you got to battle it out
if i win i keep the suit
natalie makes good points man now john
henry's making the points that natalie
used to make peppa you stay here oh i'm
not staying in the car i'll crack the
windows
dad you said she can help but she can he
can't be serious i'm surprised he let
you come this far to be honest lois
give it an hour if it looks like trouble
call the dod
where's my daughter lucy you need to
leave settle down wu i know you're only
here because of anderson and he's gone
ally had him killed to get the pendant
don't listen to her she's lying what
settles that ally is the only person who
has ever helped me that is why i wait
however long it takes and there's
nothing you can say to change it
what are you doing whatever's coming
loose
we're gonna face it together thresh on
your own
good luck guys
there's anything i can do to make things
better look at the other drawing i
messed up on two worlds no you're just
kids now go start the football season
again everyone hates me i'm never gonna
play sports again it's gonna be fine
we're gonna figure something out for you
and your brother you're a white man
you got this forgiveness will come
mrs cushing jordan now is not a good
time you need to know that sarah means
everything to me and i will kill anyone
who gets in my way
if sarah knows your secret it puts her
whole life in danger but i can keep her
safe not even superman can keep everyone
safe if you really love sarah and you
want to protect her you'll stay away
goddamn it's more about lois she still
thinks she's my mom look your sister's
need to fix you i can help her with that
yeah i don't think that's a good idea i
would never hurt you or your family
you drugged him you lied to us i did
what i had to to help ali why are you
always choosing her over your family
ally loves me after today i am done i
don't want anything to do with either of
you you're so [ __ ] annoying
keep rooting for
but god acting like they beat the [ __ ]
out of you or something growing up
buddy i know it hurts
but
you also try and focus on your good you
got [ __ ] super bad backwards man so
what is your amazing gift more amazing
than you even know you're better than
all these people have you seen the
girl's locker room lately
does your x-ray vision come in here
i'm pretty sure it did right
mom saw the video of me singing and she
recognized the bar i tried telling her
that you know who wasn't there but it
was too late and now she thinks that we
were trying to keep it a secret i'm
gonna go over there and i'm gonna talk
to her yikes she's gonna get no maorial
work done today i i got this
okay
i'm gonna dead bad
prepare my last meal if i was hard on
you it's because i thought that's how
you raised kids that's the excuse you're
going with i was a child raising a child
i'm something you're shackled to a
constant disruption in your perfect life
i'm so sorry that i ever made you feel
like you were a burden oh wow it's
actually receipt please give me a chance
to prove
how much i love you you can't just say
some words and expect things to be
different lucy you need to come outside
you guys look more and more like a cult
every day
especially now that you've dwindled
are you sure i don't need a coat
this hat's all i could find in the truck
it'll be fine once we get started
started doing what that's right
seriously
oh dope
all right uh what do we do first
oh my god he's gonna learn to fly
[Music]
push him right up
you just have to let go of your fear
jordan
i mean you'll catch me before i crash
right
you [ __ ] jordan
that is terrifying
wow
buddy
jordan
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thousand times better than punching
feedback what and that's what grandpa
lane had been doing an amateur night
all right i used to call the kessel run
uh what's up
we're stopping training to watch star
wars
we merge both planets
you can do that we can with enough power
which is why you are going to tell us
where to find
the super super
guy lucian you were getting on my god
damn nerves
then applied a special lacquer made from
ex-kryptonite ice cryptid that she stole
from my supply she used the word
borrowed
[Laughter]
hey can you uh upgrade my suit yeah
we already lost one world
this time i have to fight
okay
look how about we start with you walk me
through the upgrades on your suit
and then we go from
there okay
smart way john then you can learn how to
dismantle it that's right
steal the ideas for your own
it's just a friendly dinner with
co-parents
who happen to be raising two phenomenal
young women
they were pretty phenomenal
oh oh you're still up there but you're
still up there was it just a chance
what are you gonna do kill me like you
did anderson we didn't kill anderson
your son's other self did she ordered
him to do it lois wasn't there
he made that choice himself he's the
monster you manipulated him the only
manipulator here is you god i [ __ ]
hate you you know what die
just die lucy don't you want superman i
can get him
just die just die i don't care best
character just die
superhero landing took your brother to
the fortress for a quick training
session
yeah uh we practiced flying yeah well
don't worry about the chores i got the
whole list then by myself
jonathan i'm gonna go shower you guys
have no windows too just like no no
sense of awareness that that would be
[ __ ] annoying
yeah it's
oh yeah
god damn it
oh my god
yes take a video or call the dod dad we
need to go you know the suit will
protect me
no
come on clark
i knew it damn
[Music]
no uh
oh god
no
go max power
[Music]
[Music]
you did it
could compete meet us at the dld
cool natalie's the [ __ ] i [ __ ] love
natalie now
this whole episode
damn
sometimes
family isn't the one we're born into
it's the people we choose to love
i choose you
and i will do everything in my power to
earn that love
wow you are like the mom she never had
no what
they're holding you for observation
you got pretty banged up and you have a
concussion
got my first
i gotta go beat up an alley down yeah
i'm gonna merge okay
still unconscious but they're running
tests
what kind of tests it's not like they
can do blood work
actually they were able to draw his
blood
uh oh
there's got to be a place that you can
perform that you can legally enter
you might have put some feelers out
[Music]
he's going to want 10 i was gonna say
use your manager now
oh look at the way she's looking at you
oh my god you're back in man father of
the year over here
there's a chance he might never be the
same again
time to step up jordan he's like you now
john we need superman
then until he comes back
we are all gonna have to step up
includes you john throw that football at
her
at the very least
his powers are depleted then i will
finish him off
what will you do in the meantime
i'm just gonna hover you know
[Music]
it's like an 80s villain yeah
dude love lucy
it's good
more lucy spit-off
spin-off of her
being upset and dad always being like oh
peanut that's okay
yeah i almost just lost my whole life
and you've kind of [ __ ] over the whole
world yeah yeah that's it but uh it's
okay peanut we're good we're we're
mending this family as the world
implodes
wow
my hair looks like a painter
yes
like uh
like a picasso
hey that's who's drew the diner photo
yeah i think that was everywhere i think
it was edward hopper but i could be i
could be mistaken my art knowledge is
not as polished as it once was you're
pissing off all
all the fine arts aficionados who also
watch this channel all the people
streaming andy evans and demos are here
being like jon what gives
god that lucy girl really pisses me off
so annoying i couldn't tell
she's [ __ ] you've never brought this
up before she's annoying she is the most
annoyingly written care as much as there
were moments in this episode in
particular where i was like okay i may
be coming i'm maybe starting to latch on
to you she is the most annoyingly
written character yeah
uh yeah
i'm gonna just keep it just very simple
with that she's she's really frustrating
she's very very frustrating some it's
like i get what they're going for
like it's it's all
[ __ ] in front of you
she's in the text she's surrogated the
alley surrogate mom and
whatever abandonment issues and having
this
it doesn't matter after a point i'm like
you're a grown-ass woman just shut the
[ __ ] up and
like
be a little bit reasonable here
keg gets a minor really it really gets
on my nerves after a while
um
yeah it's it's it's really frustrating
so
it's not just this episode it's like
it's the accumulation of everything over
time i know some people defend her but
i i i don't like the way she's i like
the way she's written i i think she's
i don't even
i can't i don't even sit here ever being
like i understand and then it reaches
this point with the dad or
with general lane like you peeled you'd
be a little upset you'd be a little
ticked off
yeah i don't care yeah she's got too far
you'd be a little ticked off yeah the
world's a bit screwed at the moment
largely due to to you i i mean the most
effective moments for me were towards
that point at the
you know when they kind of actually get
through to her and then ally shows up
and then the truth happens and you know
it's
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like the beats of the story i understand
and can appreciate but it is the one
plot line that yeah and the way the
nuances are presented and written it
feels more flippant than it really truly
feels like this person who's stuck in
a a moment of anguish from childhood
that they just can't clear or something
like that and it's like i know that
we've had issues in the past with like
how the natalie storyline has has played
out which had similar symptomatic kind
of writing things of like okay i feel
like you have this note and i get where
the note comes from but with her story i
feel like they have managed to create a
solid arc out of that and now especially
that she's teamed up with her dad like
i'm really into that oh she's a [ __ ] man
yeah she's great this whole episode this
whole episode i was like damn you're
believable whatever [ __ ] seen you got
man yeah it's not it's not usually my
opinion about you yeah hundred percent
everybody's saying
you're great and they're like this is my
episode yeah i gotta i gotta do my best
yeah and it's like they and for her it's
like they they moved the needle or they
moved they progress to what's going on
for her to deal with and so that works
nicely and that complements what they've
done before but yeah with lucy
yeah i don't know there's a there's an
element of nuance that when it's
happening like that in this episode
especially but many episodes often with
this show i find myself marveling just
as much at like that scene in the barn
with
cuds clark and jonathan i was like this
is a really great emotional scene that
has its time to breathe
and you know it's part of an ongoing
problem for jonathan as well and yet
this feels so much more rich and lived
in and uh yeah it's a it's a bummer
because i feel like there could have
been
uh
so much more to really
attach to and i think that you know
obviously
the actors who plays uh you know bitsy
tilik and the guy who plays sam like i
think they're great you know even still
but yeah uh
i mean uh yeah not not the best not the
best plot line on this show it is like
the one right now that's like it just
seems repetitive too after a while
it just seems like i'm hearing
the same lines with
some rewriting yeah
like oh my god how many times are we
going to do this goddamn conversation
with her and maybe it's that it's like i
would like maybe we could have you know
the problem persists life works that way
sometimes but yeah like if we could
progress the way the writing it's almost
like what did we have her say last time
let's just kind of pull from that yeah
yeah well the cult leader all the other
people in the cult seem way more
reasonable it seemed like way more like
real people real that's what's happening
what
yeah they at least seem like real people
who have been lured into this
in in a different way almost oh yeah
okay it's it's
uh i get it i do i get what they're
doing she's more
i mean she i mean like
the the level of
having her claws inside of
lucy are stronger than everyone else and
you could see perhaps the
the purposeful choice
that
ally made
at the
signing of her book which is like ll
logos length like kind of a oh
i have an um
man this is the one to manipulate
you know i get it and so yeah he's got
more of a grasp on her soul
more than anyone else yeah it but yeah
like you said i think that's a great way
to put it what you said about how
she seems more flippant than actual
anguish and that's probably the
if it is there's a lack of depth to it
that's kind of
frustrating it seems like they don't
quite go there but everything else in
this episode was great starting to make
this immediately about her because
everything else in this episode i
thought was amazing i
adored that scene with jordan flying yes
beautiful but also that that uh that
celebration and that wonder uh catharsis
yeah and like when they're just jumping
up and down together freaking out it
felt so natural and real and their
rhythm back and forth on the ending beat
with i call this the castle running i'm
just like
like it was such like great comedic
rhythm between them and enthusiasm and
they they just really committed to that
excitement and joy i thought that was
such a beautiful moment and i like
the theme of this episode i don't know
if you guys picked up on it but it was
about mistakes that we make
and the choices that we do afterwards
i think every other everyone at the one
point in this episode said the word
mistake yeah seriously everybody
presented their big burden of their own
problems that they've created yes and
it's about you know what you do after
mistakes are made
that was everyone's story line uh and
how to how to handle it and also like
the fear of
how do we let our children make mistakes
you know the whole thing was about
mistakes
and uh i like every that's what everyone
was dealing with
mistakes made oh [ __ ]
and i think it was all i think i love
that theme and i think that really
uh hits home hard and and is a great
theme to explore for
every one of them jonathan
learning how to and i like how even in
here
it's not just people who made mistakes
in previous episodes and now it's being
carried over here like people were
making mistakes left and right
this whole episode like i liked what a
lot of see there's like such a big
difference with lana um
i feel in terms of her attitude
that
felt i could see some people getting
frustrated with it but i thought it was
very believable it was very blue
especially when she's bringing up all
that [ __ ] about like
i learned that my daughter was kidnapped
due to this [ __ ] you know i think that's
such a great reason to be like stay away
from my family yeah i i actually totally
bought into why she was so you know
because it's easy to be sitting here
and be like this [ __ ] superman i
don't do something you know they lied
but come on man you're friends with them
what the what's your deal like this guy
loves your daughter
yeah but then when you bring in those
details that i forgot about or that
don't spring to mind
her
and and she is dealing with so much and
you could feel that
again like what you said the anguish the
compounding effect of everything
her having to
just
deal with
she can't even like vent to anyone about
it you know that's the hard part too she
can't talk to anyone about it so she has
to kind of just figure this out on her
own and it's a lot of responsibility and
so i really think her performance was
great and like her laying the law down
with jordan
i
thought was a great i personally thought
i could see that scene dividing people i
i thought that was actually a great
scene and i really believed her and i
liked how freaking vulnerable uh jordan
was pleading
you know so
and the way they the way they're all so
slowly i like i don't know where it's
gonna land but the way they're slowly
bringing kyle into the fold really
allowing him to
earn his way back in
it feels very
natural it doesn't feel forced or like
this is going to be solved with some
like you know expositional conversation
that's really emotional
it's been taking its [ __ ] time and
and you and so by the time you get to
the the sit down and like you feel like
you earned his way there the way he's
interacting too does not seem like
desperate wouldn't be back it seems like
he really is you know accepting the
situation is in and obviously hopeful
like that feels really real and it has
me rooting for them again whereas before
i was like nah you gotta kick him to the
curb
but now i'm like nah you know like he
really seems like he's
he is doing his best you know yeah and
uh i think we gotta forgive men but if
this was a woman never take that [ __ ]
back never cheat her
dab i'll take it forever i'm a woman i
see you and i think of him
yeah yeah
no it's it's really wonderful and yeah i
i i love
it's funny because yeah it's called
superman lois and you expect you to
spend most of your time i love that they
at least give lana and her family part
of the actual plot where it doesn't have
to be related to superman like yeah we
just have their story as well and i feel
like on a lesser show that could be the
whole like why
i want to get back to superman this
mellow drama but yeah it's really well
like they're really good at letting
those characters make mistakes that feel
authentic and then yeah take the time to
build
just the response to that and the road
back from that sure and yeah it
complements this episode's theme really
well and everyone's performances like
just watching like i love kyle because
the journey we've got on with him like
the way that performance has
shifted and grown over time like i think
he does a terrific job with that and it
really feels like yeah this guy who has
gone through this dip and is now really
just trying to be a good
person good father
good
co-parent i love that they they even
checked that term good co-parent
you know and uh yeah i don't know this
is this this had everything like this
had me like teary during so there was
like top gun maverick it was like i was
getting teary-eyed during and dramatic
scenes during some action scenes during
any yeah this was great this was like
aside from
some of the aspects of the lucy stuff
this is like a top-notch superman lois
episode yeah you know
yeah
and now supes is a real per is a real
boy he's a real human cheering up at
action scenes a lot lately i know action
is moving when it's for the growth of
the characters man when jordan goes
flying you're like oh my god i feel so
this is cool this is really fun to watch
but also oh what a joy for you after all
this angst and trouble you know your
default reaction used to be oh
now it's
such beautiful action
punch them again
yeah man
i got a girl gotta evolve
i'll i'll find a way to cry and
at the same time just like a a tear
spray
do that
but yeah supes is a real boy now he's
good next season he's just going to be
clark kent that's what they're setting
up he's just going to write for the
paper there'll be no super [ __ ] john
henry and natalie will take over
yeah man be good and then it'll be
called
john henry and natalie
all right
[ __ ]
and hoes
and everything in between
and my bros
[ __ ] hoes
bros yeah that's the whole spectrum
sorry to disrespect any of the men up
sorry bros sorry bros um
what do you guys think
hey team lucy definitely
add her to the show title subscribe
click that bell if you want to
let's do it
adelia chamberlain adelia
you are going to be dubbed the lowest
lane of our patreon page from here on
out
you know why because you have a
nurturing quality yeah
very motherly in a lot of ways
and you also
seem to have a bit of that like
writing journalistic researching type of
mentality
in fact
this lines up a lot better than i
expected it to when i chose you to be
the one to shout out to cabrera losely
it actually lines up really well
you are the lowest lane of our patreon
page you take care of us
we are your children we're your children
and yeah
and clark was gone for a month and you
had to deal with our shiznits i'm sure
you actually watch the episode and you
know what john is referencing as opposed
to just skipping to your shout out
you're an avid fan you're an avid fan
all we talk about is this and you just
don't shut up about superman and lois i
thought you had other fandoms adelia but
adelia thank you for being such a
sweetheart we would not be here today if
it weren't for you oh so my dear
god bless your [ __ ] soul
and it's a damn good soul at that best
soul sex
i would totally just eat your soul up
i'm sure you understand the alley i'll
send that reference
yeah just bite right in
you know
thank you dude
[Music]